really sad story that went viral
yesterday as a guy a 32 year old
activist
who was stabbed to death by some vagrant
wacko at 4am in Bed Stuy and he was
leaving a wedding with his looks like
his girlfriend
and uh young white guy apparently a real
do-gooder you know liberal social
activist
um and he's there with his girlfriend
and there was a vagrant in Bedford
Stuyvesant I mentioned he's a young
white guy because bedstuy is a black
neighborhood it's overwhelmingly a black
neighborhood so this guy stands out
bedstuy is a poor neighborhood this
guy's wearing a suit his girlfriend is
wearing a gown and this vagrant walks by
and for some reason this young man this
32 year old man gets up with his
girlfriend and follows
the crazy vagrant and starts speaking to
him when this vagrant it looks like he's
beating up on a car or a trash can or
something and the guy showed courage in
that when when the vagrant pulled a
knife out and starts attacking him he
put himself in between the the attacker
and his girlfriend
and then he was stabbed
he's down on the ground and this was all
captured on camera because cameras now
are everywhere
the the sad I mean the sad part about
this is this young man died uh
some people are kind of mocking it and
saying well he got what he deserved you
know play stupid games play stupid
prizes I'm not doing that that's you
know this is a very sad thing if a guy
gets murdered especially if he if he is
trying to help his girlfriend but what's
really
what is especially sad and what's
politically important for all of us is
the shocking way that he and so many
people today
misjudge these sorts of situations right
now go to expressvpn.com Knowles have
you ever heard of data Brokers they are
the middlemen collecting and selling the
digital footprints that you leave online
they can stitch together detailed
profiles of your browsing history online
searches and location data and sell it
off to advertising companies who use the
information to serve you targeted
advertisements no biggie right well
you might be surprised to learn that
these same data Brokers are also selling
your information to the Department of
Homeland Security and the IRS to mask my
digital Footprints I am so pleased that
I can protect myself with expressvpn one
of the easiest ways for Brokers to
obtain data to tie it back to you is
through your device's unique IP address
which also reveals information about
your location
when you're connected to expressvpn your
IP address is hidden making it more
difficult for data Brokers to identify
who you are expressvpn also encrypts 100
of your network traffic keeping your
data safe from hackers on public Wi-Fi I
have the expressvpn app and look you
know I'm a Luddite okay so you can get
it on your phone you can get it on your
tablet you can get it on your computer
you can get it on your home Wi-Fi router
and it's simple enough that even I can
use it you tap one button turn it on
boom you're protected that easy make
sure that your online activity and data
are protected with the best VPN money
can buy visit
expressvpn.comles use my link to get
three extra months for free
expresvpn.com expressvpn.com Knowles
bedstuy is a very bad neighborhood
wasn't it biggie who raped about
bedstein Do or Die My bedstuy is not a
nice place I just looked up the crime
statistics in Bed Stuy your chance of
becoming a victim of crime in Bedford
Stuyvesant is about 1 in 35.
the violent crime rate is 1065 per 100
000 people the average crime rate is
2900 per 100 000 people
it was four o'clock in the morning
this is a
a young white couple dressed to the
nines from a wedding
they're gonna stick out like a sore
thumb
uh some people have said well it's crazy
to be in New York City at four o'clock
in the morning it's not crazy to be in
New York so I've been in New York City
at four o'clock in the morning many many
times all over the streets in all sorts
of parts of New York
but if I'm gonna be out on the street at
four o'clock in the morning it's when
the bars get out in New York I'm gonna
be in nice neighborhoods I'm not going
to do that in bad neighborhoods and
there's a difference between bad
neighborhoods and nice neighborhoods
and you're not allowed to say that now
because it's Politically Incorrect
to suggest that certain neighborhoods
are more prone to Crime than others but
they are
and if I see a crazy looking vagrant on
the street I'm gonna cross to the other
side of the street
and I'm not going to talk to that guy
I'm not even going to make eye contact
with that guy
because
some people are more dangerous than
others
you're not allowed to say that now
especially if the person is black even
if the person's white but especially if
the person's black you're not allowed to
say that because that would be called I
don't know they call you racist or
profiling or whatever but
these are these are all
natural reactions
that are conducive to our own safety
the the word that has been totally
trodden underfoot in recent decades is
Prejudice Prejudice is a terrible you're
not supposed to prejudge anything but of
course you have to prejudge things you
have to just act on gut and Instinct you
you don't have time to write a 50-page
thesis on every single question you're
presented with you wouldn't get out of
bed in the morning
you would you wouldn't be able to
determine okay I'm gonna get out of bed
and then eat a bowl of Cheerios and then
go take a shower and then go get my car
and drive to work you'd have to examine
every single one of those decisions
every time you meet somebody
you you wouldn't you wouldn't be able to
know do I shake their hand do I punch
them in the face do I run away
Prejudice I'm not saying you know
cruelty I'm not saying uh you know
unjust discrimination I'm not saying any
of that but but just pre-judging just
going going on your gut going with the
wisdom of the ages that is not only not
a bad thing that's a very very good
thing that is essential to our personal
safety and to politics Edmund Burke one
of the great uh Anglo Irish philosophers
of conservatism
elevated prejudice
as a very important aspect of politics
because otherwise we're going to be like
the utopian liberals we're going to be
like the progressives who say the past
was always bad we got to throw out they
had no wisdom whatsoever and we're just
going to reinvent the world every single
day out of our own stock of reason but
our stock of reason is relatively
limited and when we do that when we
ignore the wisdom of the ages we
actually put even more constraints on
our stock of wisdom under stock of
reason and we imperil ourselves
and our political Community very sad we
should pray for that guy and we should
pray uh for his girlfriend you know and
maybe even for that maniac
criminal there who I hope is arrested I
hope all the other criminals in New York
are arrested there's another sad aspect
of the story if New York were just
operating like it did during giuliani's
day then the prosecutors would arrest
the criminals and and the likelihood of
being victimized and even in these bad
neighborhoods would diminish greatly but
because of political correctness because
of liberalism because of a
misunderstanding of human nature and
politics
we don't get that and so it's no
surprise when people in in recent days
oddly enough especially
open liberal activists are are
victimized that that should come as no
surprise because
they're they're basing their behavior on
on flawed premises
it's not just bedstuy Henry queller I
mentioned Henry queller at the top of
the show he's a Democrat from Texas but
he's relatively more conservative uh
Congressman queller was just
uh carjacked in Washington D.C
I was coming in from the capitol uh I
parked in front of my uh my apartment
complex and when I was getting up three
guys came up with uh with guns uh I
quickly analyzed in situations I got a
black belt karate so you got to learn
what to do uh I looked to the left
somebody had a gun to the right somebody
had a gun I had a third guy behind me uh
and uh you got to stay calm so I went
ahead and gave me the uh the car keys
and they took off uh within a couple
hours they were able to recover my phone
my my car uh everything got returned I
want to thank the Capitol Police and the
Metro Police for doing their job
so it's good that there was a relatively
happy ending here and Congressman
Cuellar wasn't hurt and he got his stuff
back
this is a sitting member of Congress
getting carjacked you know the city has
spun out of control when that happens
years ago during the early days of the
verdict podcast
we were we were filming at me and
Senator Cruz and some of the staff were
filming it on somewhere L Street K
Street somewhere in the studio but in a
nice part of DC we're pretty close to
the White House and this was about one
in the morning you know Senator Cruz
would come over after the impeachment
vote and we'd do the podcast they just
park on the street whatever after one of
the early shows
Senator Cruz walks back into the studio
we were cleaning up a little bit and he
said guys someone broke into my car
there's a smash and grab someone just
smashed open a window grabbed stole
stuff out of the car
this is sitting U.S senator
it's a sitting U.S congressman here
quellar
how do you stop it
it's not complicated
if Rudy Giuliani could do it in New York
City in the early 90s
anyone could do it it's it might not be
easy but it is simple you have to
acknowledge that
the the way to fight crime is to lock up
the criminals you have to recognize that
the bad neighborhoods are where the
crime is likely to happen you got to
send more cops to those bad
neighborhoods and you got to harass more
criminals and you gotta lock them up for
longer periods of time when crime is on
the rise that means you have an under
incarceration problem what what are our
liberal rulers tell us that we have an
over incarceration with over
incarceration talk to me about over
incarceration when the crime rate starts
dropping again
it's it's just a a refusal to accept
human nature and reality as it is well
of course we live in a Time
when you're not even allowed to say that
is it any wonder that we're ignoring
reality on other fronts too boy what a
great clip that was now
make sure that you ring the bell
subscribe to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel
see you next time